[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy new year everyone hey I'm Matt
fire roar on the game director on the
Elder Scrolls online at ZeniMax online
studios it's another year another time
for another big announcement on Elder
Scrolls online but first twenty nineteen
was a great year for us we were mmog of
the year again we went to elsewhere it
was the first time we told a year long
story over the entire four updates of
the year it was really successful we had
lots of fun but late last year you know
we dropped some hints about where we're
going next we're really excited about
what's coming next we're really excited
about what we're going to show you today
so thank you all of you in the ESO
community worldwide ESO would not exist
in its current form without the life
that you bring to the game so thanks we
are concentrating even more on the
year-long story in a place that's very
familiar to every Elder Scrolls player
we'll be talking about the year-long
theme the chapter and how it all ties
together we're really excited about this
so welcome everyone to the dark heart of
Scotland
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage Pete Hines and rich Lambert
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's just Las Vegas talking that's
what that is
Wow yes I am Uncle Pete also known as
Pete Hines from Bethesda and with me in
pants so you know it's a big day
creative director at ZeniMax online
studios rich Lambert rich how are you
good this is amazing you know the energy
in this room is so high I get to be up
here with you we haven't done this since
morrowind since more one yep and we
haven't actually ever done this in front
of a live studio audience before and
it's amazing to have so many people from
the ESO community here together and
thank you guys for coming in and joining
us and of course thanks everybody
watching us online around the world
we're streaming on Twitch and Facebook
YouTube mixer you name it we're
streaming on it and for those of you
watching us on stream we've got some
stretch goals today as you may know last
year those stretch goals ended up with
rich getting a tattoo on his leg despite
despite his fear of needles yeah what
are our goals this year if we hit 80
thousand concurrent viewers and that's
across all of our different platforms
combined everybody is going to get a
long winged bet bat pet say that five
times fast and if we really knock it out
of the park and reach a hundred and
fifty thousand concurrent viewers rich
and I are going to be doing the snow
Bear Plunge
you know and you know I got a tattoo
because the community my hair still
purple because the community we're
getting you're probably gonna get wet
look I've been practicing my fingers at
a time and a glass of cold water like
I've already I've already started
trading for this it's happening so rich
we just took a look at the trailer from
the trailer and the name wild guess
we're headed to Skyrim we are we're
going Skyrim it is a little different
than the Skyrim that you knew and kind
of grew up with in test five but it's
gonna feel familiar yeah your long
adventure kind of gothic I mean a little
dark you got to see in the trailer there
it's dark it's it's gothic it is this
very interesting adventure that takes
you all throughout familiar places and
unfamiliar place so it's gonna feel
familiar to skyrim fans I assume we have
some of those here I mean we've already
released it like 47 times on 57
we haven't played yet I don't know what
to tell you we put it out as many times
as possible but at the same time it's
gonna feel very different in tone and
feel not only the sky room but even to
the ESO we know Skyrim as we know it in
eso because there is some of sky Romania
so there is we you know at launch
we had the eastern portion of Skyrim so
the Rift East March bleak Rock Island
and so we decided to focus more on the
western side and you know exploring what
that was and some of the iconic places
there and and dark heart dark heart of
Skyrim meaning well we're gonna actually
take you to the dark heart of sky mm-hmm
interesting and this is once again this
is gonna be a whole year story so this
is not just sort of hey come check out
this DLC when we lease it here and
that's kind of the beginning end of it
this is all year long yeah like last
year with season of the Dragon we're
telling this year long connected story
that all four updates are very heavily
tied together to tell this narrative
that was something that we got a lot of
feedback on last year with elsewhere
they liked that they wanted the story to
be even more integrated and so we did
that each of the the DLCs that we do are
all very tied directly to the story and
we do still have that big elsewhere like
chapter this time around we do so we're
kicking off the year with quarter one in
the dungeon DLC called Harrow storm and
the story of dark heart kicks off there
there's a prologue quest and whatnot and
then it really kicks into gear in
quarter two with the grain war chapter
and great more chapter is going to be
going up for people purchase like right
now so all of you want to jump on it and
pre-purchase and we'll be talking a
little later in the stream about some of
the goodies you get if you want to go
ahead and pre-purchase great more but
that'll be a bill starting today so
we're getting a new experience in a
familiar location we're expanding the
area of Skyrim a little bit but like
what's new in in what I'm gonna be able
to go and do where I'm gonna be able to
explore you mentioned okay well you've
been in the eastern part we're gonna
head west what does that mean we're
going west
it's the site of Kings Bagram
he hasn't joined the oven heart packed
so it's a very different story it's a
little bit more political it is also
this very almost supernatural dark
storyline where there are weird
storms ravaging the countryside there's
werewolves and vampires and witches and
it's kind of up to you to figure out
what's going on and how they all are if
they all interconnect however the
locations gonna feel different biome
wise like we get one singular thing
you're breaking it up into a couple how
I split it we're splitting it up like we
do in all the other chapters there's
generally three biomes when we do that
the northern portion of the zone is what
you would expect ice and snow
that's incidentally where solitude is
that big iconic city
I know Alice yeah I know you're very
tall than half you get to go have fun
exploring that and seeing it in a
different light though we're a thousand
years or almost a thousand years before
the events of testimony so it's going to
be a little bit different and then as
you kind of progress through the zone
you move more towards the lowlands so
rolling hills a little bit of you know
that Tundra Arctic boggy feel and I know
you know there's some interesting
locations there that you're pretty I
mean certainly both when it was in
development and then afterwards just for
fun I spent a ton of time in Skyrim both
for work as well as just for having a
good time and unwinding from work so
yeah very familiar with solitude and
some of the other places that we're
gonna be talking about you mentioned the
like we're gonna be visiting these
places it's a thousand years in the past
but you guys are not doing the same kind
of one-to-one that you did for say the
more wind chapter where it was much more
about hey you know this part of the
world from this game and we're gonna
kind of recreate it you're taking a
different approach here in dark art
chuckle oh yeah we want it to feel
familiar but we also want to go off and
forge our own kind of thing and so we're
telling different stories we're taking
you to those familiar locations
you know solitude and why not but we're
also going other places and really
diving deep into the dark heart of sky
so this is going to take place both
above ground and
although you and I both know the first
question fans love to ask when you talk
about you know going to a new place is
okay how big is it is as big as this as
big as you know down to the square inch
they want to know size-wise
but this especially this community they
but this is a little this is a little
different in terms of like if you just
look at it on the map it's actually not
gonna appear as big as some of the other
ones but that's a little misleading
you're right so it's not one whole
contiguous space you know there is the
Overland space which is Western Skyrim
and then there is this huge underground
cavern down below Skyrim called black
reach and we're gonna spend you're gonna
get to spend a lot of time down there
yeah by the way this is not like hey
it's really big and it's like this one
thing over here we're talking like yeah
do percent forty percent of the playable
landmass for the chapter is down in
black reach you're gonna go to never
before discovered locations in black
reach so I mean vampires werewolves they
don't like being out so they they've got
a whole underground they do you're gonna
get to find out more about what that is
and who's down there and why they're
down and but it's not just underground
we're going to some places that we are
familiar with above-ground we mentioned
solitude north all north all is there
and it's that same kind of feel you know
that creepy foggy boggy kind of area
there's a twist in it in our timeline we
won't spoil it but it's gonna feel
similar but different interestingly you
know the thing I remember about more
thaw in Skyrim is that's the first place
I came across vampires while playing the
game because you go there's the house
burned down in the poor little girl and
you've got to figure out what happened
to the house and there's a vampire lord
who's trying to trying to take over
north also cool that that's in there and
that's gonna be part of some story that
you don't want to tell us I don't want I
don't spoil it too much is it safe to
say it's a vampire like like ish yes and
black reach now black reach is an
amazing area in the elderscrolls v
skyrim it's also really friggin hard to
get to like I don't know if any of you
have ever tried to get to black reach
you have to
swim all the way to basically where you
think the game is gonna you know cut off
the map through ice floes and there's
some random hermit in a cave who's like
oh I have the magic flues it to let you
get into the black we're talking about
like doing this and that I'm like okay
well what are the some of the locations
and black reach did you ever go there
and I was like no what where the hell do
I get the black reach and I'm wandering
around like oh I have to have some
stupid artifact to get into here and so
like once I got it and I got to go in
there like oh my god it's it's amazing
it's this huge cavernous okay but that's
also the beauty of what that team does
right where you can play the game for
hundreds of hours and still not discover
everything that's massive it's just
round it's really amazing and so we
tried to do a lot of the same things in
ESO and so how do you take something
like black reach that exists in Skyrim
in some form but what you're doing with
it obviously is a much bigger scale it's
not just gonna be to the size like
you're you're going even we're going
bigger you know they're the places that
you know from test five are there but
we're going deeper and exploring there's
actually multiple different types of
biomes in black earth within black
regions with the in black reach so while
you're wandering around you're gonna
learn more about the creatures there and
see some very interesting things there's
Dwemer ruins down there there's vampires
down there like you said as well so lots
of cool stuff dragon bridge dragon
bridge is in there so you can just see
that and explore that and there's some
sort of on the dungeon side underground
places I remember like shadow green
which is a really interesting unique
cavern in scar very different
thematically labyrinthian any chance we
see we have both those so shadow green
is Adele where you get to go and explore
that it's a little bit different we're a
thousand years in the past so some of
the trees probably aren't as big as they
would be and then labyrinthian is a very
large public dungeon so you get to go
around and explore that and just see
what all that is in there but again all
of this is kind of you guys taking some
some locations that we know but making
it your own in terms of how big they are
what's going on there you're not really
tied given the difference in time
we get to do it on investing I tell our
own stories which is fun there's a lot
of new ground to cover in Tamriel when
you've got that but there's more than
geography talk to us about the story
like what what is the story that you're
telling across the year of dark heart of
Skyrim what is it about what a players
gonna experience it is a very dark story
it is I guess the closest thing you
could relate it to is Reve inspire for
those that you know play that you know
that that feel that really dark feel if
centers around vampires and werewolves
and which is and people disappearing and
it's very different than what it
elsewhere was you know elsewhere was you
know dragons which were really school
big bulky creatures but it was in the
land of the Khajiit and the Khajiit are
you know these little bit off the wall
very happy-go-lucky people and that's
not what the Nords are at all and you
said this is similar to how we've done
in the past like what we did with
seasons of a dragon so so functionally
rich is it breaking up into the same
number of DLCs the same types of DLCs
what what can players yeah so it's it's
the kind of typical for major updates
over the course of the year there's two
dungeon DLCs there's the chapter and
then there's also the story DLC that
culminates the entire year okay and two
of those you mentioned so Harris storm
and gray more and gray more and then two
more coming we have two more coming that
we will talk about at a later date maybe
e3 yeah all right now one of the things
you guys do a lot in when you do these
chapters when you do these DLCs is
you'll bring npcs back that are their
player favorites either from you know
previous storylines and elder scrolls
online and and you you and I both
laughed and we were over there waiting
to come up because we got a big reaction
was very yeah is art she's bad or
something born is back for sure she is
[Applause]
she is your guide and mentor throughout
the entire year Jennifer Hale Jennifer
Hale is back as in the voice of lyricist
so that's really exciting and then yeah
one of the things that the team really
enjoys is trying to bring back
characters that people who else could we
expect Desai slurs everybody's favorite
hated dark elf and nurses trend is back
we are going to Skyrim so of course
rigor at the brash is gonna be bad
course you're gonna get to see you know
and learn more about who he is and what
he's all about and then we are also
gonna have some members of the Raven
watch which are excellent so we've got
some places that we know from from
previous Elder Scrolls games some
characters that that were familiar with
and this really interesting story it's a
lot of mystery going on but one thing we
know for sure is that there's no mystery
about how excited your team is in doing
this and the things that they're doing a
dark hardest guy we spoke to some of the
devs and asked the ask them to share
their thoughts on making dark heart of
Skyrim and put together a little video
let's take a look my favorite part of
playing through Skyrim has always been
that layered storytelling that turn a
corner and something new is going to
happen and some new adventure is gonna
kick off right and that influenced us us
in the way that we build the Elder
Scrolls online and it certainly
influenced us in the way that we've been
building dark art Schuyler
as a storyteller it's always exciting to
take existing locations existing lore
expanding upon that and then merging it
with new places that we're creating
we've seen East March before we've seen
the rift that we're going to see what's
going on on the western half of the
continent it's ruled by a guy named King
safar grim who is not at all happy about
the fact that he's got Joran making
friends with Dark Elves and argonians
Kings far Grimm didn't join the oven
heart pact he's operating on his own and
he's not kind of happy with the rest of
Skyrim reach men are a threat but
there's more threatening the people of
western skyrim now it's a much more
darker more gothic story every Nord
knows the legend of black reach they
grow up hearing stories around the
campfire nobody believes it's true it's
one of the best moments from Skyrim you
descend down into the ground and you've
emerged into this absolutely insane
dwarven city that you had no idea was
under your feet the whole time and we
are taking that idea and we're kind of
expanding upon it like it's not only
under that one part of Skyrim maybe this
cave extends throughout the entirety of
Skyrim and it's always underneath your
feet wherever you go you know the Dwemer
have been down here and what else has
been down here of what other adventurers
are down here so deep underground out of
the sunlight of course you're going to
encounter vampire
vampires and elder scrolls they are all
evil which is kind of scary - where did
this strain of vampirism come from what
makes these vampires scarier than other
vampires we've encountered before we
really wanted this part of Skyrim to
really be familiar to people if you're
in more Thal
you know that if you go south you're
gonna get to labyrinthian we want people
to step into solitude we want people to
remember those streets I was gonna flip
a table if we didn't get to go to the
weekend Skeever now we didn't get to
call it the weekend Skeever
but we still get to go there and that
was that was far enough for me it feels
like going home to a certain extent
coming home and finding there's a new
room waiting for you in the back of the
house that's full of mystery surprises
and a lot of deep
you know you know it's a hardcore
Elder Scrolls group when they get jazzed
over a winking ski like the biggest
response to the videos for the winking
ski BRR
okay so we've talked about we're gonna
do this story over the course of the
entire year over these DLCs and I want
to actually skip ahead and not skip over
here a storm let's talk about grain war
and first of all what what is great more
what so green war is the name of the key
that's deep in the center of black reach
this is one of the seats of power for
the vampire Lord that resides there and
the story you know touches a little bit
on him but the chapter overall is
follows the same kind of pattern that
they all do in that there is roughly 30
hours of new content
there's main story there's side content
in there you get to learn a lot more
about the people that are living in the
area and then there's also all the other
trappings that usually come along with
that in to public dungeons there's a
number of delves there's a new dark
anchor like form of gameplay in the zone
called Harrow storms and then of course
there's a new 12th player trial called
coins ages
[Applause]
well they do they're making Mike very
happy and as is available for
pre-purchase now there's two other
things that are coming in this that are
like interesting conditions above and
beyond everything that you just rat it
off and the first one is called
antiquities it's a whole new system and
we put together a video talking a little
bit about what it is so let's take a
look at that first antiquities are
really super exciting particularly for a
lower buff like me it's not combat it's
not questing it's the first time we've
added anything like this since how's it
so it's a whole new verb to add to your
adventure and repertoire so antiquities
is divided into two different kind of
exciting activities the first is scrying
player will get an item called the
antiquarians eye which is this really
cool alien scrying device you'll have to
use the antiquarians eye to discover
where this antiquity might be hit and
when you find where that antiquity is
hidden then you'll have to excavate it
once you've obtained the antiquity then
you've acquired this treasure from a
bygone era you'll get to find things
from eras that none of the Elder Scrolls
games have touched yet that should give
players really cool insight into the
history of Tamriel which is something
that we're all really super passionate
about so I think this will fill a void
for characters and players who want to
explore more of Tamriel history like
we're already in the second era which is
before any other Elder Scrolls game but
with antiquities we can reach even
further back into the past and start
getting scholarly insights and fragments
of history from times even before that
another cool thing about the antiquity
system is is that if you're looking for
an opportunity to do something that
doesn't involve you like storming a cave
and kicking an ogre in the face this is
a cool way to do that it you can go and
travel the world and find cool stuff
they're going to be in base game zones
they're gonna be in chapter zones DLC
zones and zones that we released going
forward they're going to be everywhere
it's mostly about you and the open road
and
equities you can find okay so
antiquities are a big deal and as we
said at the end of that video not just
specific to this part that we're adding
to its it's gonna incorporate the entire
games game line a past president and a
future in future how does it work what
how does it take these words so I guess
the best way to summarize kind of the
feel of the system would be Indiana
Jones in Tamriel so you are this person
that is scouring the countryside you
know looking for interesting bits of
lore interesting relics you know as the
guy said on the video this is not your
typical questing and killing it's a
completely different form of gameplay
where there's these two new minigames
two new skill lines that are associated
with those minigames that help you get
better at antiquity antiquities you know
the first minigame scrying is heavily
influenced by a color or a shape match
game and that's what you do to zero in
on the location of these these objects
and then you have to physically go to
that location in the world and do the
excavation minigame the digging minigame
and that is heavily influenced by like a
minesweeper or battleship and once you
dig up the item you get this cool thing
and the the really fun part about this
system is we tried to appeal to all
types of players you know there's kind
of something in there for everybody you
know when you dig up the object
obviously you want a trophy for your
house so there's tons of new furnishings
you can put them in your in your house
[Applause]
there are
all kinds of new cool cosmetics for your
character you know there's all types of
stuff in there there's emotes there's a
brand new mount and the really astute
person watching that video might have
seen it in that video there I think we
might show it a little bit later and
then there's a brand new type of gear
that you can get called mythic items
there's even PvP stuff there is there's
actually a siege weapon that you can get
nice I mean first of all I mean you had
a solid Indiana Jones so cool done
mythic items what are they how they work
these are new unique items they only
come at CP 160 Gold level gear so
they're high-quality items they're
different in that you can only wear one
of them at a time and they have unique
properties to them so a couple of
examples there is a piece of jewelry
that you can get that when you equip it
it increases your movement speed in
combat when you're outside of a combat
it actually doubles that movement speed
so it's this new interesting way to kind
of play the game and equip your
character there's also a heavy chest
that you can put on that when you block
it actually restores Magica so and but
you can only have one of these you can
only equip one of them at a time and
again the whole idea is for Antiquities
is regardless of your play style a it's
not a like go kill a bunch of stuff or
it's not a quest thing this is at your
own pace when you want and there's gonna
be stuff for every type of every type of
player and the beauty is is really you
know this is a system that you can do at
your own pace and so those players that
might not necessarily have access to
guilds or you know a ton of friends that
can go in to the trials and do that the
high-end stuff they get some really cool
new gear and new gizmos they can do that
and tell you yeah
so we said two things one of which is
antiquities the other is you're
revamping the vampire skill line
dark-hearted amping vampires
yeah I mean this year is you know
heavily influenced by it by vampires and
so we thought it would be a really good
opportunity to go back and look at the
skill line and look at the experience
and the team looked at everything from
the abilities to the passives there's a
brand new ultimate ability that I won't
spoil with it and it's this whole new
package so it's this fully realized
skill line and experience so you can
like necromancy if you do overt vampire
actions in the world the justice system
will report you cards you'll give
bounties and then the team even looked
at just the feeding mechanism in it of
itself and we becomes like a page from
the dark brotherhood and blade of woe
we're now feeding has these really cool
new paired animations where you feel
like you're actually feeding I actually
saw a prototype animation just before
this where you know you kind of sneak up
behind somebody and you jump on their
back and gnaw on their neck and there's
viscera and gore and cut all this like
it is a vampire experience which is
really cool I am curious when you're
working with something like a vampire
skill line is is sucking like a stated
goal
the vampire stream all right yeah the
last one I don't know that again yes all
right so now you know me I have a pet
peeve about this which is I can't stand
when a game company or publisher says
there's never been a better time to play
game X everybody always says that but
there's a lot of people who maybe either
haven't played Elder Scrolls online for
a while or have never played it and so
the question is without saying that how
do you explain to somebody all right I'm
thinking about getting into this game
but you've got dark heart of Skyrim and
gray more we've got more win we've got
all of this content like how do I know
where I'm supposed to jump into this and
and start so that's the beauty of Elder
Scrolls online is it's really up to you
you know we don't have arbitrary level
gates that prevent you from playing with
your friends are going and exploring you
can from level 1 go to the brand new
content and play it and experience it
and have a good time you can play ESO
any way you want you know if you want to
be a mage in heavy armor and a shield
you can do that if you want to throw
fireballs you know you can do that as
well it's it's it's up to you and we
don't dictate to you how to play if you
want to play Elder Scrolls online as a
single player you can do that and then
when you're ready you can play with your
friends so dark dark heart of Skyrim is
something that I mean like these folks
play a ton of the game maxed out there's
still lots of colors then for you and
the thing but if you're new and want to
jump in and have this be the first thing
it's not like well you got to go do this
other stuff you can start off in grey
more date up and do from level 1 and
just start playing cool now I know that
these folks in particular and some of
our more hardcore players were not super
happy with us about something with
elsewhere which is we decided not to do
a collector's edition for elsewhere and
they were like dude what the hell
where's our collector's edition we love
the collector's edition so we heard you
and we're doing one this time around
[Applause]
so we are doing a physical collector's
edition it comes with a really sweet
statue some collectors coins a map every
Elder Scrolls game has to ship with a
man I think it's a law until a ton of
digital goodies a whole bunch of stuff
including an ammo pack that I mean
because we haven't driven arrow to the
knee completely into the ground yet we
had to have an arrow to the knee a mode
and it comes with a free month of Elder
Scrolls online plus which you can either
use for yourself or if you've got a
friend if you're already an ESO Plus
subscriber you can gift it to anybody
that you want so yeah and that's always
I mentioned before pre-purchase
available for graeme or there's all
kinds of digital goodies available if
you want to pre-purchase great more it
includes an all-new mount the whole
breaker warhorse
and if you pre-purchase grade or you can
start using the mount immediately so you
don't have to wait until grade more
comes out you'll get them out right away
and can start riding around go to the
website for all the details and info on
everything in the seee and in the
pre-purchase goodies so okay i said i
wanted to start with gray more but now
we're gonna go back to the first one
that's coming out so the first one is
new dlc it comes out this quarter Harrow
storm it's gonna be on pts and x3 next
next week it'll be on pts so what can
you tell us about heroes so harris storm
is you know a two dungeon dlc it
contains the prologue which really kicks
the story off for for the entire year
and the the dungeons themselves one is
called ice reach it takes you to the sea
of ghosts and you learn more about these
really weird storms you know i touched
on those a little bit in the ice reach
coven and the other dungeon is called
unhallowed grave and that is an ancient
burial site that was under protection
for some reason was heavily guarded and
has since kind of been forgotten about
and there's a group or somebody in there
digging up whatever was entombed in
there
okay and you said before that you're
really trying to do more of the story
earlier on and not just waiting for okay
here's this big chapter in quarter two
so Harris storms gonna include much more
story in terms of what's going on what
you find out in the dungeon lays a very
strong foundation for the entire year
now the Hera storm update is not just
about that deal so you're also doing a
bunch of updates to the game itself as
part of that release later later this
quarter
what is that could include so back in
July I think it was we posted a
performance roadmap update upon Elder
Scrolls online comm and we've been
updating it over the course every month
we've been updating here's the progress
here's where we're where we're going
with this you saw a little bit of that
at the end of the year with some of the
memory memory improvements that we did
but this year the very first really big
one is the patching overhaul and that's
gonna cause everybody or require
everybody to redownload the entire game
but once you do the game's gonna be
significantly smaller on disk almost 30
gigabytes smaller which is massive and
it's gonna result in the game running
faster loading faster frame weights
gonna be a little bit better and hatches
going forward are gonna be smaller
shorter down times smaller patches
improve stability all of all stuff is
coming starting with and this isn't the
only one but this is the start this is
the start of the entire year like that's
the other big part of this year long
story is the performance aspect of it
all right so here a storm coming out q1
we put together video to talk a little
bit more about about what you can expect
take a look this your adventure into the
dark heart of Skyrim starts with Harris
storm which focuses on two dungeons Ice
reach and unhallowed great
discovering the mysteries in these two
dungeons are a gateway to the larger
dark heart of sky our ice reaches this
island in the middle to see it ghost and
there's this mysterious storm swirling
about so an expedition was sent there to
figure out what's going on and they
haven't returned once the player arrives
on the island in search of the missing
expeditionary force they come across
Lyra Titan born and they team up with
her in order to discover what the
witches are doing on the island and put
a stop to this mysterious storm as you
travel across the island you're gonna
come across multiple witches each with
their own type of magic somewhere
getting's fire some are gonna use
electricity and they also have other
minions and creatures that they're gonna
bring to fights
on how a grave is this mass burial of
bones that has been underground and
sealed away for thousands of years by
the pyre watch and it's been so long
that what exactly is down here is
actually unknown to them and they
appointed people to watch over it
they had one job to do and they couldn't
do that right because somebody broke in
not only is the player gonna have to
deal with the Nordic mercenaries but the
defenders that the ancient higher watch
left here to guard the tomb and you were
discovering what was left down here and
what the Nordic mercenaries are looking
for
[Applause]
what's a box
you want to know what is that you're
gonna tell us what that is you'll find
out next week so we've got Harris storm
coming mid-march but it's gonna be on
pts next week we've got great more
coming out in q2 anything else you want
to tell us about what's coming 20 20
maybe second half of the year yeah I
mean we've only touched on quarter one
in quarter two we're gonna talk more
about quarter three and quarter four you
know Eddie three but one is gonna be a
dungeon dlc and the other one is going
to be that story dlc okay but we got I
mean we've got all these people here
like like whatever what if we just
promise just in this room what if you
just tell us just in this or just us
like a little teams like like something
all right I like that that's good so as
long as it just stays in this just in
this room just to misremember turn heads
in Vegas stays in Vegas
I like that okay okay how about this if
you are at all interested or familiar
with lore about the reach you might be
really excited about the coming fourth
quarter okay so so maybe your so you're
telling me there's a chance we're going
there's a chance okay well find out more
at e3 okay but for now we got Harris
storm we're looking forward to gray more
any last words any last thoughts you
want to share with folks yeah I mean I
think this year is poised to be
remarkable for eso
you know we've got all this really cool
new content these new systems coming in
the community is continuing to grow and
expand we have actually seen you know
our Russia community grow significantly
over over the past year or two so we're
actually going to localize ESO in
Russian so text-only
there's a lot of friggin text very small
but yeah there's there's gonna be a
fully supported official localized
Russian skew that's awesome and I mean
entirely due to the community in Russia
he was supposed to support the game have
been so awesome and
one of the thing I wanted to ask you
stadia we were part of the stadia stuff
and we got a few questions like hey what
what's up but that we get that a lot
yeah and we haven't forgotten about it
we're still hard at work on that and
we'll probably talk a little bit more
about that at e3 awesome okay I think
that's about it rich thank you so much
thank you this is a blast thank you
everybody for coming up thank you guys
so much for joining us in person and for
everybody who joined us on the stream we
are gonna go right to the post show but
before we do let's take one more look at
the trailer for dark arts garment
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so welcome to the official post show we
are live in Las Vegas at the HyperX
Arena super excited to be here this is
our first time with a live audience it's
so cool we are going to be talking with
everybody for the next hour so getting
into a little bit more detail about
everything that we just announced on the
stream so first off let's introduce
everybody I'm Gina
I am one of the community managers for
the Elder Scrolls online I'm Jes Folsom
senior community manager on the Elder
Scrolls online we have rich Lambert with
us who you literally just saw
I just wanna copies here is purple yeah
and do you guys want to introduce
yourselves - sure I'm Lehman Tuttle on
the lower master for the Elder Scrolls
on my name is Kyle I am an ESO stream
team partner and I stream mikail
dempster student well it's twitch.tv
forward slash Kyle Dempster studios and
my name is Kasia from the lower seekers
podcast you can find us at Laura seekers
podcast.com alright so let's dive right
in so we just wanted to talk about our
viewership milestone rewards so I'm
happy to let you know we did unlock the
long winged bat pet so it's the log into
the game and kill one monster we'll have
more details on the ESO website tomorrow
so keep an eye out for that we did not
hit the snow Bear Plunge number you all
been so great and we love you so much
we're gonna do it anyway
[Applause]
so keep an eye out for details are you
Deb's house that's it yeah women also
the dark or the gray more chapter is
available for pre-purchase right now on
the Elder Scrolls online comm we have an
article up on the website that will help
you choose what version is best for you
you get a lot of really cool
pre-purchase rewards including the hold
breaker warhorse
which you can get right now is actually
people running around in the game with
it right now I'll bet and there's also
physical collector's edition we heard
you we know you wanted one so that one
is available for purchase pre-purchase
right now as well and it comes with this
really cool vampire lord statue not
Venus we have a sale going up on the
Bethesda merch store right now ten
percent off the code word is Skyrim and
you can get ten percent off select items
there's also a whole bunch of really
cool new dark heart of Skyrim items
including the reliquary we all agree
again I'm not the wedding alright so
what did we just announce we announced
our brand new chapter which is grey more
the new year long story which we're
calling dark art of Skyrim for this year
the Harrow storm DLC there's a lot that
we need to think until the show and
that's just mentioned that you can
pre-purchase gray more now we know
there's been a little hiccups on the
website a little bit but if you're
having issues getting in there we are
working really hard to make sure that
you can get in and pre-purchase again
you can check out all the website for
all those different items that you can
get including the physical collector's
edition so next week we're kicking off
with Harrow storm coming to the pts
which is super exciting includes two new
dungeons the prologue quest is going to
be on there we have the patching
overhaul the performance updates which
we are going to be talking about in a
couple minutes mm-hmm but first but
first we've seen some questions coming
up within the community in the last 45
minutes or so since we
finished our announce stream there's one
that we want to address and we have some
some questions from our players on
PlayStation 4 asking where is the gray
more chapter why can't i pre-purchase it
yet
so due to circumstances outside of our
control the chapter is not available for
pre-purchase at this time on ps4 but
please know that we have you covered we
will make sure that you are able to get
the pre-purchase items you'll have the
opportunity so just keep an eye on the
official ESL website and social channels
for more information one of the other
things that I saw coming up a couple
times was with Antiquities there are
some folks asking if we're gonna
accommodate colorblind mode for those
that can't see the colors and some of
the puzzles we are definitely taking
that into account so have no fear you
will still be able to participate and
that's why it's she really good shapes
and colors
alright so rich you just have a few
moments before you need to head out so
we don't want to take too much of your
time but we did want to start with here
oh yeah so we want to kind of address
the elephant in the room first which is
game performance because we know this is
really important to a lot of people you
want so can you provide an update on
sort of the current state of performance
because I know some people maybe haven't
played in a few months they've heard
some things
what's going on with performance right
now well I think that the first big
thing is we actually had a successful
undaunted event finally got that
that lfg tool you know the team worked
really really hard on it they completely
rebuilt it from the ground up and it you
know stood withstood this event which is
great there are a few things that shook
out of it we're still working on it's
not perfect yet but we're still going to
continue to work on it and make it
better but it it made it through which
was great sweating but yeah great work
so update 25 this is coming to pts next
week this is gonna include patching
overhaul frame rate improvements but
what does that actually mean to a player
what are they going to notice we're Matt
the big thing is a the game is gonna be
smaller on disk together
yeah they don't know the entire game but
once you do that it's gonna be roughly
30 gigabytes smaller which is good does
that also mean that the patches after
that will also be smaller they will be
smaller going forward on all platforms
on all platforms which is really
important we know that's a pain point
for players and the other big part of
this is just the game is going to load
faster you know it's gonna load more
reliably less than finit load screens of
doing I know that's the thing that
happens
[Applause]
and your overall frame rate is going to
be better because of the loading system
can just load the assets fast
so question because this games big and
it takes people a while to download it
based on their internet is there any
kind of incentive players might have to
do this yeah so what we're going to do
for a period of time after it goes live
is there's going to be a free pet in the
crown store that you can purchase I
think it's the crimson torch interested
in that so that'll be there is kind of
an incentive to hey go through
redownload the game but get this really
cool neat things critters in Merc Mara
wasn't it I saw a lot of people asking
before like how do I get that torch Bob
unwanted yeah yeah for sure
it so you mentioned the framerate
improvement so that's across all zones
like even in Seattle even Rock ah
so keep in mind that this isn't a silver
bullet that magically fixes all problems
all yours
this is the first step in many
performance improvements that we're
working on but it's a very good first
step okay can i button again please say
hey so rich my game crashes a lot I
might get a little bit of an add-on
addict I don't know why I'm not
admitting it yet I'm not ready for that
it's a hundred okay or more will this
help at all any of these with crashes or
anything like that so it won't help your
problems
we actually have an incremental going
out that fixes a number of memory leaks
so I know players have been talking
about you know I'm in Serie dough for
instance get away for a few hours and
the performance just kind of goes down
you know it takes longer to load my
framerate doesn't work very well and we
fixed a couple of memory leaks
specifically to address that that
actually went out this morning that was
30 today so thank you save me
so since this is hard question time I
guess it's my turn to dig into you a
little bit so I'm one of those players
that logs into the game and I like the
game to just run smoothly like I don't
know any of the backend stuff I really
don't carry any of the backend stuff
about anything back and stuff I just
want my game to run smoothly so at this
point I guess my question is are we
going to fix the fact that my character
still runs on top of my mount or
[Applause]
can we make it a freakin achieve I mean
at this point it's kind of like an
easter egg I mean it's been in the game
for as long as I can remember it's
probably not gonna get fixed anything
what about the one where your character
literally humps the ground we might look
at that one but the so rich what about
update 26 the the base game patch is
coming with graeme are there any
performance updates coming for that one
no no no we've got those on our roadmap
I think one of the big things there is
the multi-core support you know getting
in there and really utilizing more cores
on your CPU to better offload the work
of the game so that things can a little
bit faster a little bit more optimally I
have something here my notes about AoE
ability types more specialized on the
server what does that mean my eyes just
glazed oh yeah so one of the things that
the engineering team and then the combat
team have been working on is looking at
how area of effect abilities are run on
the server you know when you cast an
area of effect there's you know the area
and it's got a pick you know how many
players are in there who's in there
who's the right targets and so they they
optimized that specific type of ability
so that it just runs better on the
server that sounds like would have
pretty big impact there is per spirit
outwards yeah to really improve things
way yes cool all right well we don't
want to take too much more of your time
you know you have a lot of interviews to
do so thank you for joining us yeah we
are actually gonna swap rich out with my
Finnegan hybrid while we do that
about to really starting good I highly
do so we're gonna show you guys a quick
video while we swap these guys out this
year-long adventure into the dark heart
of Skyrim starts with Harris storm which
focuses on two dungeons Ice reach and
unhallowed grave
discovering the mysteries in these two
dungeons are a gateway to the larger
dark heart of sky our ice reaches this
island in the middle to see it ghost and
there's this mysterious storm swirling
about so an expedition was sent there to
figure out what's going on and they
haven't returned once the player arrives
on the island in search of the missing
expeditionary force they come across
Lear's titan born and they team up with
her in order to discover what the
witches are doing on the island and put
a stop to this mysterious storm as you
travel across the island you're gonna
come across multiple witches each with
their own type of magic some leggings
fire some are going to use electricity
and they also have other minions and
creatures that they're going to bring to
fights
on how a grave is this mass burial of
bones that has been underground and
sealed away for thousands of years by
the pyre watch and it's been so long
that what exactly is down here is
actually unknown to them and they
appointed people to watch over it
they had one job to do and they couldn't
do that right because somebody broke in
not only is the player gonna have to
deal with the Nordic mercenaries but the
defenders that the ancient pyre watch
left here to guard the tomb and you were
discovering what was left down here and
what the Nordic mercenaries are looking
out of the mine
[Music]
[Applause]
I see you've got the memo about what
color we need it yes black dark art of
Skyrim rich was very green I don't know
how he's that we just watched a video
about the Harrow storm DLC which your
team is working on a couple of dungeons
for that we're gonna talk about those in
just a minute but first we want to dive
into a brand new system which we think
maybe you guys want to hear a little bit
more about coming with frame are called
Antiquities so we've talked a bit about
that yeah so antiquities are really rad
I'm really excited about it it's a
really awesome system I know rich spoke
about it at length or anything but
basically when you break it down it's
two minigames that allow you as a player
to travel around Tamriel and find all
sorts of really cool stuff and cool
stuff includes you know things that you
can put in your house like this like
this guy right here Ruby dragon skull
and it's awesome all sorts of you know
things like emotes and then things that
players can use in combat a little bit
of something for everybody so let's talk
a little bit about how the system works
because it is a little bit confusing
when you first hear about it so how do
you kind of get started it with
Antiquities right so when you get into
the dark heart of Skyrim and you go to
solitude for the first time there's a
group called the antiquarian circle and
you go and you speak to them and they'll
run you through a short tutorial that
introduces you to both mini-games
you get a chance to hang out with fan
favorite Gabrielle we haven't seen her
in a long time from the base game yeah
exactly yeah
again it's like the bride side all the
Gabrielle so so yeah you get to hang out
with her she walks you through the
system and then you're pretty much off
to the races you get to go find cool
stuff from every you know historical era
of Tamriel I got a question about the
the way that that actually works because
I admittedly suck at this game in
regards to the mini game if you're
better at the mini game does it or worse
at the mini game does it change the way
that your rewards are delivered to you
no I mean during the mini game you can
redo it if you don't think that you've
done a good enough job and when you it's
it's not going to be really there's not
gonna be a large barrier of entry for
players don't feel like oh my gosh I
messed up on the antiquarians I and I'll
never find anything we try to keep it
you know accessible for everyone so that
everybody can take part in the system so
it's no adult tantrums like I have in
via well no but
to mention what he said I mean there is
a skill element to a master element to
where you gonna get better than where
you do it and the more you practice a
lot like VMA well
yeah there's a mastery element to that
we want you to kind of like focus on and
get better at doing including two skill
lines that are specific to the antiquity
system itself awesome so we kind of
heard this when Rich was up on stage but
I think any time a new system like this
is added to a game players may have the
question is this going to be scalable
rich mentioned it very briefly but like
it's gonna be in the old world it's
gonna be in in Skyrim is this something
we are gonna maybe see going forward
absolutely that's one of the coolest
things about it is is that it's kind of
baked into the cake with Tamriel
generally so it'll drive you back to
previous zones you haven't been in every
open cake it is a cake it's a cake of
milling later
layered cake but yeah you're gonna go
back to every region of Tamriel that
you've been before and the antiquities
that you find there are appropriate to
the space that you're in so if you go
back to Alec here maybe you'll find an
ancient yo Kooten relic if you go to you
know if you're hanging out in Skyrim we
might find something from at Mora
so there's all sorts of really
interesting like really deep dive
historical lore things and find any
Imperial stuff cuz Imperials don't
really have a whole
the biggest non-combat activity that
we've added to the game since Ozzy
absolutely and it's it's it's something
that if you need to take some time off
and you don't want to be you know
killing a bunch of things you can just
kind of as that activity you can go out
hang out and the things that you find
though apply to any kind of game style
that you can think of so you have things
that you can get in the antiquity system
that are great for combat things in the
antiquities system that you can get that
are great for furnishing your house it's
a little bit of something for everybody
so everybody will be able to engage in
the system and have a really good time I
think rich mentioned what son know it's
bound good question there Bell that's
not actually a very fine on Eclipse
the items that you get the are by to
choose their bind on accounts yes so I
think rich mentioned the siege weapon
for PvP that's a brand new siege weapon
the players think it's really rare to
I've seen it it's nuts he also mentioned
the special amount that you can get and
this is only available through
antiquities we actually have a
screenshot if you guys want to see
[Applause]
so yeah you can only get that mouth
through antiquities edits
pretty badass you know it's not like
your basic horse it's cool another thing
rich mentioned was the mythic items and
and I kinda want to touch on that
because they're they're one-piece items
you can only you only wear one of them
so you could equip it and the idea
behind the mythic items is it's not just
combat related or anything like that
sometimes it's gonna change how you game
how you play the game so when he
mentioned the jewelry piece that
increases your your your non-combat
speed by double I mean that's perfect
for people going out in the world and
hunting crafting nodes and doing
everything like that so they're gonna be
able to zip through the world and do
stuff so it's kind of gonna these these
items are not just designed to like I'm
a better in combat they're also designed
to cater to different kinds of gameplay
that's cool I heard a question from the
crowd the amount is it something that
you get whole or do you put it to you
find pieces and put it together I
believe so you put it together put it
together
[Laughter]
label or hound I do have a question
about the antiquities and the lore
perspective do you have is there a way
in game for us to kind of track the
things that we found and where we're
going with with finding some of these
relics so one of the coolest things
about the system is is that where as
Laura's developed it's it's delivered
through the world in our game we don't
you know come in and say this is what it
is as you're finding things there are
different characters who will add text
to a journal where they'll explain oh we
think it's this we think it's that we
think it came from here well I don't
know and so there's gonna be a lot so
that that ambiguity is going to be
carried through the whole thing and so
so it'll be a lot to read and a lot to
learn let's go along and yeah it does
add on to it as you progress through
exactly's get more bits of that like
honestly see like guilds being formed
after this system I truly do for the
true Laura's podcast appeals there's so
many players I mean we've talked to
three times now at this point but the
fact there's PVE pvp and all of this it
brings together the community at large
into this and I think that's something
the game is needed so huge kudos I know
you've talked a lot about on your we'd
really like something to do that isn't
just quest around oh yeah well you don't
want to fish all day long I mean
officially it's great but it does go to
show it's like digging is like fishing
in the dirt
mentioned we will definitely have an
article on the website explaining
antiquities when it gets a little bit
closer to pts this is in quarter two
with the chapter and so let's move on a
little bit to the vampire we want to
kind of sink our teeth into the vampire
skill Linus rich mention is undergoing
some changes so what's sort of the goal
behind I hate to say it again but
revamping the vampire well it's it's to
make vampirism feel more visceral I
think that's the biggest thing is is
that we're presenting kind of a power
fantasy for every kind of vampire
through the new skill lines
so there's abilities where you can
mesmerize people like Count Dracula
there's abilities where you can you know
take life away from people in a really
kind of like feral way like with you
know this crazy eviscerate slash so
everybody who wants to get a real sense
of what it's like to be a vampire in
Tamriel this is a great place to do it
so as rich mentioned before we're doing
all these new animations paired
animations where you can you know jump
on people and drink the blood and stuff
and we've also gone back in the vampire
quest tutorial and revamped it to my
series else we're talking about I'm
going to go elsewhere
but yeah so the the new quest is gonna
bring you up to speed on how the new
system works and it's it's it's really
sweet I think it's really cool yeah it's
also like like vampire before was it was
cool and all but it was kind of like one
passive right like people like got this
and then they kind of hung out got this
passive the undead passive and they're
like all right I'm just gonna hang out
with that and get my batch go back or
whatever so now it's more active
actually even kind of flip the script a
little bit like before the less you've
fed the the stronger you got and then a
new vampire line in order to make it
active the more you feed the stronger
you get so we're kind of flipping around
that paradigm that if you want to be a
vampire you want to be a badass vampire
you have to feed and get stronger and
your look change --is to write as yes
actually and that's another thing too is
before your look would change the less
you feed and now it's the more you feed
you're looking that's it we're done here
okay so you guys know I'm a huge Questor
a huge lore nerd I do all that I don't
spend my time dancing an hour
that's later so we have this amazing
statue of vampire Lords sitting there we
do are also taught in previous Skyrim
that they're kind of very rare and
they're not something we approach I'm
sure some community members are out
there wondering how are you guys
approaching it without making it feel
overly normalized or anything sure that
yeah I know
should we get into the old forum I think
you see we've said you didn't wanna
spoil them sorry that's him I'm sorry
so yeah yeah hold off spoil the vampire
skill line is that the player is able to
turn into what we're calling a blood
scion which is much of the vampire and
it's yeah there's there's there's
definitely there's been a lot of debate
in the lore community about is the
vampire lord form is that exclusive to
the volkl our clan that we see in test
five LOM a mother llama is the you know
kind of the mother of vampires she can
manifest her vampiric powers in a lot of
different ways and since the player gets
their powers directly from La May and
the right the right of the Scion or
whatever your you know she gives you
that ability to turn into that form so
you know the Loras lore sound don't
worry it's in good shape we got this
lore because of pretty sure it's pretty
clear that I'm a big Laura nerd but
anyway I want to ask a question
specifically about all the different
vampire clans because you did mention
the Vulcan Hart clan and it's if you're
gonna open the door where I'm gonna go
right through my question is is it's
specifically in Skyrim are we gonna see
anything it sounds like all the
different skills that we're gonna get
are kind of different in each way
are they reminiscent of some of the
different vampire clans that are present
in Skyrim in throughout Tamriel
absolutely yeah so we're not going to
deal a lot with walk our claim they've
got you know Lord Harkin has a lot of
plans that are in long time term
development so III bro right now yes but
yeah the the different iconic vampirism
abilities are all going to be present so
vampiric drain the the ability to you
know feed like you would in previous
titles and yes so you're definitely
gonna feel like all the the you know
greatest hits of vampirism in Tamriel or
for sure nice awesome sounds like
vampires have a lot to look forward to
in the next chapter so we want to talk
about how how does this fit into the
overall chapter help we want to talk a
bit more about grimore and the zone in
which it takes place so let's dig into
that a little bit sure gonna use it
again a lot army yeah so Skyrim that we
present in in grain war and dark heart
of Skyrim is I mean obviously it's it's
almost a thousand years before the
events of test five so the situation is
very different rather than you know
battle between the Stormcloaks and the
Imperials you have this kind of cold war
brewing between West and East and the
East you've got King dorren who
everybody knows him from the original
release he's hanging out in the oven
heart packed with jelly elves the dog
onehans now West the High King they're
they're actually too high Kings right
now so the High King in the West is King
Safari and the the West is much more
isolationists they're much more you know
kind of standoffish but they're also
they're very proud nortz they're Nords
Nords you know when they talk about
death and sovngarde they mean so players
will get a chance to hang out with with
this this different group of nerds and
the way that the plaque the power
struggle between sparred room and what's
going on with the rest of the world
plays out plays a big role in the quest
itself what about the art direction so
there's gonna be areas that people have
seen before in the Elder Scrolls 5 and
then there's gonna be some newer areas
that they have a really experienced
before so what what was kind of the
general art direction for our version of
Skyrim yeah I think that hits the nail
on the head right it's it's presenting
Skyrim in a way that's unique to Elder
Scrolls online so you get the you know
the best of
you know test five and you know going
back to kind of the greatest sets of you
know it's it's solitude it's black reach
its you've got you know labyrinthian
there's all these really cool places
that you can go but we've also like I
said it's thousand years in the past so
there's a little bit things that are a
little bit different there's just enough
that that if people played ts5 that
they'll get it like you go to solitude
and you kind of see there is every house
in the same place I don't know you know
what I mean but like I've walked through
it and it's everything but as you're
going through like that some of these
little like shacks and stuff like that
might not be there because they haven't
been built yet or something like that
but very much like you walk through the
major point since the major cities and
you're gonna recognize there's a lot
like we did in in Morrowind or or any of
the other areas can we take a moment to
talk about the fab so LuAnn Giles we
could I think rich actually set this up
earlier but this zone is split in a very
interesting way because people in the
community were speculating dark harness
Chiron does that mean we are in black
reach what does that mean a 60/40 split
I believe is what we're looking at this
insane what inspired that kind of need a
huge dynamic shift like that well I mean
I think black reach is just a really
cool area players got a chance to run
around in there you've got you know
giant glowing mushrooms and drummer
ruins and and we were able to build upon
that and you know add even more a black
reach and different types of biomes like
you saw during the video Graham or keep
is is kind of a warmer palette so you've
got different types of cave environments
to explore and yeah I've you know I've
been running around in there you know
during development and yeah it's it's
it's wild it feels it does not feel
small it feels big and and that's also
part of like the story also very much
drives this kind of thing so like you go
into black reach and stuff like that
it's not it's not forced or anything
like that the story is driving you down
there it makes sense you know if we're
talking about vampires this is a place
that doesn't get like
and it just makes sense that they would
that's where they would build their
Kingdom economy so speaking of not
getting lights I imagine that would
allude to the fact that we're possibly
going to see Falmer Wow well you know no
it's you know during our time period
Falmer this is again it's not test five
when people talk about farmer that's
it's that's ghost stories like oh
there's these weird things that come out
of the ground sometimes and I think you
know they Joe's goat a few weeks ago so
that's pretty much every fall yeah yeah
but but there's there's a pretty good
chance that the player might encounter
in the fall I got a question because you
guys sent out these amazing maps the
community members right and many people
here's like it's fire how great any
chance we can know what those mats
actually mean should we should we review
all okay so yeah when you when you put
those maps together
I think the community did an amazing job
of today's
[Applause]
next year 400 different maps so yeah
when a lot of people were pretty much
there when you line up those maps and
exactly the right way if you take a look
at it the markings on the map correspond
to the major locations in the gram or
chapter so you've got more Thal solitude
Dragon Bridge and a number of spots that
might become relevant during writes
there are some some parts that you might
look at and go what's this you'll figure
it out
you will the night before Daedric is
really freakin hard to decrypt I got I
got to tell you man hats off because
they did not make it easy for you
[Laughter]
everybody should get on duolingo that's
right the Daedric course is googling go
man the time period a little bit so how
did the general time period in eso
versus Skyrim like what's going on
during this time period when grammar
takes place and how did that inspire the
the tone and the general vibe of the
song yeah it's it's it's a really cool
time in Tamriel like history for you
know a lot of reasons there's a lot
going on in Skyrim like I said there's
you've got that that cold war brewing
between the two halves of Skyrim and a
lot of times one of the cool things
about doing what we do is we're able to
tease hey this is how things might
resolve and there's there are things
that happen in this quest that might
kind of determine the trajectory of the
region generally so you know for those
of you who are wondering you know are we
how is Skyrim gonna stitch the wounds
back together again and see how things
are going and over the course of the
year you might figure some of that out
but yeah the the in terms of tone the
Western Skyrim is it's it's much it's a
hard place it's a cold place full of
grumpy people
we just went a bit that inside it's a
bit similar to riven spire and
absolutely filed yeah that Gothic tone I
think is where we were going that that
feel or lighter yeah you're you're
walking into vampire land yep I was
already bleed over from any of the blade
is there any crossover between any of
the stories that we may have already
played through the base game and to what
we're gonna experience in scary
well the inclusion of leader Satan born
that's a big one
[Applause]
like rich said everybody's favorite dark
elf to hate nurses trans Iran is back
River near amo we've got rigor rigor to
prayers tightened boring there's there's
a ton of characters who wouldn't come
back at all here some members of the
raven want yeah including like the
speaking of bruising rivets fire we've
got some members of the raven watching
might show up you will have to wait and
see who they are so I saw somebody
mention when we were playing the CG
trailer at the start of the show some
people in twitch chat were like who's
that woman and why she's so big like
why are you going over everything else
well first I'll say you guys should play
the main quests but yeah she has giant
blood in her veins and that makes her
real big yeah
she's our snow she's a badass she's yeah
all right so we're gonna shift our focus
a little bit from grimoire and Skyrim
the zone talk a little bit more about
the trial that's the 12 player context
[Applause]
is the trial coming up and the gray more
chapter why don't you talk a little bit
more about that I know I don't have to
beg you talking about a trust why
whatever she said yeah so kynzie just is
it takes place on an island that
actually is in TS v skyrim but it's it's
just a island and go to in mine and
stuff like that so what this is this is
where the I what the island was before
it became a barren wasteland and what it
is is the north of Skyrim and it's like
a bulwark that's why it gets the name
kinds Aegis which is the shield from the
north of Skyrim so it's there to fishing
and mining but also to protect against
northern invaders and coincidentally
that's what you're doing when you get
there is you're telling a northern
invasion or an invasion from somewhere
so let's talk a little bit about the
size is it similar to any previous
trials yeah I think that when we hit
elsewhere we got that's that's like that
was a good good good model going forward
larry's what did I say elsewhere yeah
elsewhere no the whole trial is as big
as
it's 475 bosses afraid no it's big it's
as big as Sun spire there are three
bosses there's three hard modes
unlike Sun spire it doesn't it has a
more linear approach where you go from
boss one two and three you can't take
the first two in any order and we think
that that size was was pretty good and
people had a good experience when they
go through there also the three
different hard modes gave this level of
varying levels of difficulty that people
could challenge themselves and push
themselves so as they get through one
hard mode then they can go and try it
another hard mode if they can't do it
they're not out anything they can just
complete it better important question
for all the collectors out there I'm out
that's everything in between
last year with sun's fire you introduced
amount behind of an achievement oh my
god yes behind the big achieve yes the
big one are you looking at something
similar this year we are indeed it will
be just as hard as Sun spires
achievements so it's not gonna be for
everybody but it's gonna be pretty cool
why are you looking at me I was offering
dance lessons so it'll be behind some of
the the hardest content but we are
planning on doing that again yeah I'm
not gonna tell exactly what it is yet
but it's it's pretty gonna be pretty you
know it's cool I dunno
what about other types of rewards for
those of us that maybe aren't good
enough to get them out
we got the standard we're gonna have a
skin reward we're gonna have the armors
and and all that jazz that I do so yeah
all that super special stuff that we
always throw in the trials have y'all
done anything new or different with the
trial nope I'm just kidding
we commonly people kind of skip the the
base pop or they they blow through it
and they just kind of group stack and
kill and stuff like that so we've played
some extra focus on the base pop to make
it a little bit more challenging and
players have to kind of think about that
stuff think yes I know I know it's new
and different then can you talk to me
like I'm a kindergartner what the heck
is baseball so base pop so base pop is
commonly for Jewish trash it is all of
the not bosses in the dungeon so the
monsters that yeah now you get in that
narrative I don't call it trash because
they have feelings so for our final
segment we are going to talk a little
bit about the first DLC coming so this
is really our only opportunity to sort
of give a preview of this DLC before it
hits the pts so next week where's my
tears are reliquary of to you so like
start with ice reach which is one of the
dungeons new that is in this DLC one of
the great things about doing these
dungeons is it gets to have me as a
writer believe me got to be nice I hope
gets to have the lore master as their
lead writer for your Laura masters yeah
yeah don't diminishes it
matter so let's talk a little bit about
ice reach what's kind of the history
behind that yeah so ice reach is another
island in the sea of coasts where the
ice reach coven basically has their base
you guys might remember Dorota from
previous dungeon content yes yep this is
where her coven that's the seat of their
power and the player is directed to go
Joran the sculpt King sent a bunch of
nerds to check out this island because
there's huge storm brewing and it was
sinking ships and the people who went
out to go see what's going on they never
came home so the player goes out meets
up along the way with layers Titan born
and yeah Breck's faces and solves the
mystery of ghosts and people didn't come
back I know I'm a trend here it's we're
building off a dire for us so you guys
is a Selene last time you know that's a
continuation rapid Moriah from wrath
stones exactly so are you guys moving in
that direction of kind of giving some of
these plots extra parts yeah I mean
that's we always like to kind of take a
look at not just the path of our game of
the paths of Elder Scrolls games and
bring that we did it was I kind of if
you look at the Elder Scrolls past Fang
lair which was in I think arena and then
we brought that kind of like into our
world and so yeah using things that
we've had in previous done just kind of
flushing out their stories and telling
them and finishing him so Dorota of ice
reach had an interesting story in dire
Frost but now you get to see where she
came from and the and her sisters and
the coven that she came from dungeons
this guy is a really big thing for me
and I know how to hear that argue loves
of dungeons we actually go into lower
mode and just kind of slow down and we
absorb the story we don't I really love
laymen please say that you're proud of
me for doing this I'm super proud of you
for doing thank you
were you just fishing for compliments a
remind it's a minuscule peppy but I do
have a pet peeve Oh some of the NPCs
particularly Thor aya hide behind a
freaking rock while we're doing all the
work in these dungeons so my question is
can we expect
leiris Titan born so that's a big thing
for the characters that we're doing this
seraya has very much scholarly and she
didn't kind of get her hands dirty but
leiris is a badass and she absolutely
she's not gonna be a damsel in distress
you don't you don't say what's pretty
funny is is you you meet up with her
you're not you're not following her
she's not grouping up with you or
anything like that but what it is is
you're going through different parts of
this island and she's going through so
when you meet up with her it's like in a
swath of blood as she's just cleaved
like several people and then she comes
up and talks to you she's like I got
[ __ ] to do
yeah and she goes off to other people so
it's pretty funny is the stuff that you
go through and you get to fight you can
imagine she did ten times worship I
don't I don't think there's a scene that
she shows up in that she does that she
doesn't receive somebody to dish it's
exactly right it's exactly right every
time you see her she's killing all right
so let's move on to unhallowed grave
which is the other dungeon
yes that's the one you saw with the
grappling hook yes grab the hook the
universal grappling hook simple all
right so what's going on in this dungeon
you grab him hook
[Laughter]
the the dungeon is a deep dark cave in
banker I where something has been buried
away for a long time so long in fact
that the people who are guarding this
grave in large part don't know what even
what it is
and there's it's a dark horrible grave
that a number of Nord mercenaries are
taking ashes and bones and stuff full
out of it and you're tasked with
learning what the heck is going on why
are they doing that and trying to put a
stop to it that's pretty much it well
wait there's a little extra though I
think someone told me there's some
mysteries down there that you might have
to try extra hard to find so this is one
of those things that we're trying to
avoid because I really want to watch
streams and stuff like that people
bigger Wow but there are some secrets in
here that are gonna be great you don't
want to take a long look around when
you're cool stuff in here got it and I
know the grappling hook really yeah yeah
[Laughter]
there's nothing more satisfying than
finding a spot way above your head that
you cannot travel to caressing that
grappling hook and just flying to that
spot so we love that mechanic we're
happy to see that that mechanic is going
into some of the dungeon content well
wait do you play in other words or
something big at the very top and then
gravel too
I get it but is that type of mechanic or
more creative things like that's
something that we can look forward to as
dungeons evolve in eso so yes and no so
whenever we do a dungeon and put
together some some pieces and stuff like
that we always take a look at how we can
challenge create new gameplay moon grain
is a good example we had the moving
block and we got the idea to putting
this on pressure plates to open open
gates and stuff like that
so when we saw the grappling hook going
in for for Dragon well we're like
alright we got to take that we got to
see what we could do with that potential
and we did we kicked it up kind of it's
not just traversal it's used in boss
fights it's used in renew and
interesting ways and boss fights there's
all kinds of like cool new traversal
elements to we're going to challenge
your dexterity so but as far as
mechanics like that we're always looking
for for new and interesting mechanics we
can throw in there and it's absolutely
if we see something that we think is
gonna be cool and new and interesting
and fun to use we're absolutely use it
well what about rewards why can you get
from these dungeons we have the standard
items that you get the the rewards like
item sets and stuff like that but they
so the two rewards for the veteran
completing veteran versions of these
dungeons and ice reach you get a weapon
motif this first time we've offered the
weapon style and it's even you get
lyricist battle axe as a weapon style
and for unhallowed grave we actually
have these really cool new body markings
which are like they're like textured red
that looks super cool when they when you
put them on it's tough and their body
markings so they're not so they kind of
play well with skins too so you can
actually I'm I'm interested to see what
people kind of put together yeah
nations with with this stuff too so
that's what's and then there might be
some other stuff exciting yes I don't
have them yes we do item sets and
there's also serial crafted sets you
know that in an update 25 yeah yeah so
that will all be detailed in the next
week yeah I think that's unless there's
anything else you guys have any
questions for us let me add to against
calling out those so in the past you and
I've had this conversation before we
have so I think I think you know what
I'm saying in the past there's been kind
of the trifecta achievements completing
hard mode speedrun no death now you kind
of moved away from that a little bit in
the previous last year's dungeons is
that seeing a return can we expect
something like that you mean it's four
so we help we have those achievements
right when we go we we're tying we kind
of like the the incentive aspect of
adding a title to it rather than rather
than the the overall overarching reward
and that's mainly because we want to get
more people to be able to feel good
about running these dungeons or running
these rewards and stuff like that so and
we only have so much time to do all of
this things so if it was up to me with
every achievement has its own we don't
have that much time so and we want to
incentivize doing these these are these
are like the landmark achievement so you
know like oh I want to do this because
this is the thing I get so we're gonna
incentivize that but for the most part
the veteran is gonna keep that that
cosmetic reward and then the title is
gonna be offered for the pinnacle kind
of thing a lot of lines of God Slayer
and God's lair isn't Sun spire and stuff
like that's such a cool title
that can stand by itself very cool yeah
very cool I got a quick question for
layman and it's switching gears a little
bit I wanted to talk just a real quick
about the prologue quest until that
prologue quest and that the lore kind of
ties into grabbing you in and just
throwing you right into into a lot of
the parts of the Skyrim that we're gonna
be able to explore such as black reach
so how does that tie in if you're
starting player just getting right under
them for a long well I mean the the
purpose of a prologue is to kind of whet
your appetite for the chapter that's
upcoming so there are elements it's one
of the cool things about Harris storm is
they're elements of the dungeons that
kind of tie into the prologue so there
are things that you discover in the
dungeons which inform the prologue
activities and the quest there and I
think by the end of your time doing the
prologue quest you're gonna have a
really good idea of you know who are the
major players what is the major you know
plot that we're gonna have to dig our
you know dig into during the chapter
release so yeah I can't wait to hear
what people have to say about it
they kind of like rats um but it's a
little bit more obscure so like in Wrath
Stone you got both houses of Wrath stone
and you're like oh these are two things
and then you go to the prologue and he's
like all right this is what it is you're
like ah that's cool so in the name the
dungeon you're actually finding two
pieces that you don't necessarily know
how these two things relate or until you
do the prologue and then we do the
prologue and you kind of see the two
things you get you're like oh that's
what it was and it conveniently explains
the name of the the DLC yes so getting
in the dark that's that's one of the
coolest things about those dungeons is
at first glance they don't look like
they're connected at all right and over
the course the prologue it all gets tied
together it and it part of the whole
DLCs I mean when the we not the DLC is
update 25 terrorists on people like the
half is a Harrow storm right so you're
like yeah well you know after you play
through all of it you're like oh I know
what a Harrow storm is now and then
you'll be like a lore buff yeah and
you'll get to see actual heroes somebody
like what's a hair of some you're like I
know what this is yes
you'll get to actually see them in the
chapter in green yes one capsule here
you get to see a storm chapter yeah I
think everybody not even literally
looked up everybody for tuning in both
on the stream and then our audience this
[Applause]
pile cash thank you so much for joining
us on our diary and blitz Robert
I mean rich Lambert yeah rich Lambert is
off
[Applause]
[Laughter]
xD dimension thank you all so much and
everybody here this has been so special
for us this has been our first live
audience you can pre-purchase the
grimoire chapter right now and we have a
lot of good information on the Elder
Scrolls online dot-com including a full
skew article which will help you see
which version is right for you what's in
the seee and everything you need to know
and don't forget we do have a few
streamers that are gonna be streaming
live from this event al cast and Ninja
six one for starting up first in about
twenty minutes and then we'll have hey
pal okay we'll be streaming in about two
hours so they'll be live from the event
be sure to check out their channels
they're gonna have maybe some exclusive
dev time maybe maybe some popular maybe
whether they want it or not
okay slowly get in there yes next week
and thanks again for joining us thank
you thanks guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]